so mom yes today now I'm 40 years old we
are two grown women and now you live
with me I am now starting to date again
how am I going to feel confident about
dating and my new life if you are still
gonna be this way if you tell me to -
who you dating I won't want to see that
person I wonder if they will talk to
them to see how is it okay from there I
can back up this is all a bunch of BS
okay cuz know what yes yes it is what
does be S stand for bush how do you
spell pose I didn't Bo oh Sh I T boat so
one time I decided to show my mom who I
was dating one time I showed her but I
showed her on my phone she do real quick
you know hey mom look it and I put it
back down she memorized the person's
first name don't say the name she
googled this person's name found out how
much he made found out what shows he
worked on but he's in TV found out all
the stuff then she went to his Instagram
account followed him followed his show
and commented I to mama my I know to
genie my i watching you eyeball I'm all
emoji yes I introduced myself but you
can't go on the gram and do it in front
of millions of followers and you don't
want them to know that you know them
well we haven't even known each other
yet that's okay I did one Wow just like
Instagram but uh people come say hello
to me I sit out today I you my mom I was
so embarrassed about that he never ever
messaged me again we even had a date the
following doesn't mean something wrong
with him not something wrong with you
and me that's something wrong there's
something wrong with you - he's not
honest you sit up no I should he should
talk to me and he caught up with you and
let you know mom you're saying something
on his Instagram which means you're
saying it in front of millions of people
but who I Ono everybody who knows this I
just say I'm a mama my they don't know
what song on only know
you know so it's really hard to date in
these streets the divorce is really it
was sad but are you say just nasty
divorce just say stray better nasty
divorce well instead of having bad
energy go towards anybody else or the
situation I just wanted to get positive
energy to myself so I spent a year
really really taking care of myself I
got myself to a healthy weight I started
to learn what I felt and I like to be
strong so after that year I came out I
felt full I felt whole and when you feel
really good about yourself and confident
about the way that you love yourself
you're ready to go recognize what that
love feels like coming from someone else
so that's when I kind of knew that I was
ready to start dating I also wanted to
make sure on the other end that that
other party had moved on and that was
great and I did see that and so I felt
like okay there was no disrespect
because I do have a public life and I
don't want it to see in a certain way if
I've moved on and someone hasn't not
that you should dictate your life based
on the other person but it just is nice
to see that everybody kind of has the
same flow
[Music]